environment secretary is with us mr
eustis good morning
lovely to see you uh freedom day may be
pushed back at least a fortnight is what
we're hearing in the papers this morning
um what credence are we giving to that
well look the prime minister's always
said he's going to take this a step at a
time
and that with each set of relaxations
they're going to basically assess the
data when we get there so we can't make
the final assessment until the 14th of
june that's what he said
all along and we obviously don't rule
anything out the the critical test
really
is are those uh people with the new
variant are
people who've had the vaccine uh getting
infected they've been a couple of cases
i think
not many it's encouraging and we're
obviously making good progress on the
vaccination
but it's too early to say yes what we'll
do we'll be announcing that next monday
okay um apparently there was a briefing
yesterday to the prime minister and
others from valence and whitty
suggesting the figures are at this stage
grim
uh which side are you on on moving it
back or not as we speak today
well i'm not sure i would say it's grim
in that we we've seen an
increase yes well we've seen an increase
obviously in the
uh infection rate so that's gone up uh
it's ticked up if you look at the graph
that we're all seeing now in the news
every evening it's gone up that's for
sure
but what we're not seeing at the moment
is that uh growth in
hospitalizations associated with it and
that's because we know that if people
have the vaccine particularly once
they've had the second jab of the
vaccine
it actually does give them immunity uh
to
this new strain that's around but there
have been a few cases of people who've
had the double jab who then gone on
still
to get that uh to get infected again and
that's why we need to
look very closely at this watch the news
in the morning as well as the evening
yes of course one of the biggest factors
of course is the um
india variant if only we closed our
border
a little bit earlier when we did with
pakistan and bangladesh that might have
made all the difference
well this has been a dynamic situation
all along things moving very quickly
we closed the border to bangladesh
because
we were seeing if the people arriving
from there a higher incidence
of the coronavirus and you know although
you know we also know that india was
testing uh much more so
the the numbers that they were picking
up you'd expect them to pick up more
because they were doing more testing as
soon as we saw
that surge in india as well we obviously
closed the border so
we we review this all of the time um the
the travel bans
every um few weeks we're reviewing who's
in those uh lists
and india was added as soon as the data
supported that well i'm just looking at
the figures i mean ed conway
our economics editor was looking at the
figures on our behalf quite recently
25th of march to the 7th of april and
these are nhs testers trace figures
um bangladesh was at 3.7
they were put on the red list india was
at 5.1 percent
of people arriving uh had tested
positive and yet
they weren't put on the red list why do
you think that was
well look um this was obviously a few
weeks ago my understanding is
that uh india had a higher incidence
rate that it was reporting but that's
because it was doing more testing
figures here not not what happened in
india but when people were arriving in
this country
of those arriving according to the nhs
test and trace there were more a
bigger percentage of people from india
who were positive than bangladesh and
yet we put bangladesh on the red list
well i'm i'm not sure i mean um the data
as i understand yes well as i understand
it and matt hancock made this clear at
the time
initially the uh incidence of the uh
virus in people arriving from india was
lower
and overall uh while they were reporting
uh high numbers of cases
that's because they were doing more
testing now i don't know the date of
that particular there may be march to
right well um i haven't seen uh that
particular data i have to be honest but
my understanding is
uh that the reason we put bangladesh on
the list earlier
is that they uh they were they were
seeing higher instances
i mean i mean their figures were lower
look they're the ones at the top the top
bar
yes because we're lower well i know that
they were um they were testing less and
so reporting fewer cases
no i'm talking about nhs test and trace
once people came into the uk well we
were also looking at
factors such as their ability to do uh
genome sequencing and
you know we're looking at all of this
when we assess other countries their
ability to be able to pick up new
variants of concern for instance
and india does have better testing in
place than other countries about the
figures in the uk not about what
happened in india or indeed the other
two countries that we talked about
was it a political decision no it's not
so they regularly review this
based on recommendations that come from
sage and the the joint uh biosecurity
committee
they look at that data and they make
those assessments at the time but we
were very keen for the prime minister to
go to india
at that time around that period weren't
we because you wanted to do a trip we
wanted to do a trade deal
with india so it was in the interests
of the british government to keep the
border open with india well
i mean it's fair to say that well i i
don't that's not
the reason so the prime minister was yes
due to travel to india
but we then put india on the red list
and that obviously
was cancelled a couple of weeks before
he was due to go that was a couple of
weeks after you did it with pakistan and
bangladesh
yes but i mean as i said my
understanding is and this was covered at
great length at the time
that we had fewer concerns about india
at the time because they
were testing more and also because uh on
arrivals
my understanding is that they they were
showing a lower uh incidence rate
certainly lower than pakistan but not
lower than bangladesh by any
major in bangladesh uh was at 3.7 india
was at 5.1
when they were arriving here in the
united kingdom i was reading a report
from um he is associate professor in
cellular
microbiology dr simon clark and he was
saying
that uh he felt that it was probably a
political element because the uk wanted
a trade deal
with india and the prime minister wanted
to go that's nonsense
yes that's been dealt with at the time
matt hancock's been asked
i think he's explained at a great length
that the criteria that we've been
applying when assessing who should be on
the red list
what the incidence rate is that's
reported but also their capacity to do
testing their capacity to pick up
variants of concern um the incidents of
those that are arriving so there's a
range of factors that are
looked at it's not just one single
measure yeah and india was added as soon
as we uh
saw a spike in rates and as soon as we
thought saw there was a reason to do it
and as the rest as they say is history
on reflection do you think it's
appropriate that the british government
apologize
for not closing the border sooner well
look we're going to have a
a review into the whole pandemic and how
it was conducted there's going to be an
inquiry that starts next year that's
going to look
a great depth at everything right from
the beginning of this pandemic right the
way through
how people reacted uh if there were
lessons to be learned then we should
wait for that inquiry to do its work and
then we'll learn any lesson we certainly
closed the border very quickly with
portugal haven't we people had to get in
by four o'clock this morning or
thereabouts
swiftly moved from the green list to the
amber list do you think
probably on balance is better that
people holiday at home this year
well look basically now there's no uh
the very few countries on that uh
green list our advice all along has been
uh don't travel unless it's absolutely
necessary obviously we had hoped uh with
these uh
uh three categories that we had we'd
hoped that the situation would be
improving in other parts of the world
that we'd be able to progressively add
other countries to the green list
sadly that's not the situation we do
have this new variant of concern
first identified in india that is now
cropping up in other countries
and we've just got to take a very
cautious approach the most important
thing is that we can
continue to open up our own economy get
back to life
as normal here the biggest threat to
that is that we would have a variant
come from another country
that would find a way of getting around
the vaccine that's the biggest uh threat
to us at the moment that's why we should
be really cautious yeah
so do you think people i don't know
would you rather holiday in iceland or
would you go down
to your home county of cornwall i should
be yeah
i'm sure but what should people what
should people do should they risk a
green list given that people have had to
scurry back very quickly
well look people will make their own uh
individual
judgments on what do you think i mean
it's a very dynamic situation it is
um i will be staying at home i have no
intention of uh traveling or going on a
holiday abroad
this summer some people may but they
have to understand that there are
obviously
risks in doing so because it is a
dynamic situation but i think most
people
will probably decide this year to stay
at home
holiday at home we've got some fabulous
uh places to visit in this part of the
country not least of course uh cornwall
although it'll be a very very busy
summer i'm sure then and that's the
right thing to do
i i think um my my advice to people
would be
a holiday at home we've got some great
places here there aren't many countries
that are on that uh
red list but obviously you know some
people will want to travel abroad
there are still a small number of
countries on that green list
if they want to do that they can but
obviously they'll have to understand
there are risks in doing so as well
and with some of them get the map out as
well i didn't know where some of those
places were
a lot of g7 leaders of course coming to
your home
uh county do we have a special
relationship with the us
i think we always have uh had a special
relationship with the united states um
where important uh allies
uh have been now uh ever since the
second world war we've been through a
lot
uh together as uh as countries so yes we
are important allies uh always have been
regardless of who's in the white house i
read the prime minister said today that
it makes us sound
needy and weak to say we have a special
relationship
well um it depends how you use it if you
see the special relationship as meaning
that
um we always have to go go to the united
states to um you know work with them on
things
people may see it that way but actually
a special relationship could also be a
special bond of trust where you work
together on things and that's what uh
our relationship is i mean we
we do need a trade deal with them and we
would be weak without it
we wouldn't be weak without a trade deal
with the united states no but obviously
we would like to do a trade deal with
the united states
we'd be weaker with that one wouldn't we
well um you know
we we've got trade deals with other
countries around the world we do a lot
of trade with the united states we have
a trade surplus with them they are an
important trading partner
uh of course it would be good to um get
a trade deal with the united states if
we could get one on the right terms
uh brussels are very cross with us at
the moment as far as uh trade deals are
concerned there they're threatening
a trade war if the uk overrides the
brexit treaty
uh had a government minister sitting
where you are yesterday
um and she said that the deal with the
northern ireland border in or the
the irish sea border is harder than
anticipated
do you agree well i think what you have
to bear in mind is that the protocol
always envisaged that the both parties
would show best endeavors
to make the northern ireland protocol
work and that included
recognizing that northern ireland was an
integral part of the uk
and that you should support the free
flow of goods to northern ireland what
we really need
the eu to do is to respect that part of
the protocol
and put in place sensible measures to
remove things like the
nonsensical ban on selling sausages or
chicken nuggets to northern ireland
not just requiring paperwork but
actually having an outright ban on some
of those goods that clearly
doesn't make sense it had always been
envisaged that there'd be a
joint committee process and specialized
committees that would look at some of
these technical matters
to iron out the creases and we just need
the european union now to engage in that
process and
talks i think are starting this week um
indeed so lord frost
very much engaged but do you acknowledge
that it is harder than anticipated this
deal
um even though you were told at the time
by former
prime ministers leader the cbi um people
like that that
it would it would be a very difficult
process
well i um what i would say is um we'd
obviously hope that the european union
would engage uh more fully uh in the
joint committee process
and in those specialized committees to
identify solutions to
some of the issues such as a ban on the
sale of sausages in northern ireland
which doesn't make any sense
other issues as well such as if you're
delivering goods
and you're a supermarket and you're
going direct to store
in northern ireland there's no risk of
those goods ending up into in the
irish republic or in the european union
in the single market
so that could be recognized and special
measures could be put in place
so there are solutions that are there um
using digital technologies to make this
work we're committed to
making it work but we just need the
european union to engage in that process
to iron out those issues
sausage and chicken mcnugget wards that
sounds um enticing let's see where that
takes us over the next
few months i wanted to ask you about a
report from jeremy hunt
uh he used to be the foreign secretary
was before that the health secretary as
you know
a colleague of yours he's now uh
chairman of the health and social care
select committee um he says nhs staff
are suffering
from burnout and they are not being
supported the way that they need to be
by the government
what would you say in response well look
we had a manifesto commitment to recruit
more nurses an extra 50 000 we've
already recruited
12 000 nurses you know we are expanding
funding for the nhs we are recruiting
more staff
yes of course they've had a difficult
year um you know if you're dealing with
a pandemic
as they've had to it's been a very
difficult time they've done
extraordinarily well
we are doing all we can to support them
but the critical thing
there is that's what he said well i'm
not sure what more we can do they've
worked very hard
well um there's been a pay rise and
there's a review uh looking at that
issue
uh again but we're we're also recruiting
more staff and if um
if the issue is that they feel under
pressure and it's that's
entirely understandable having been
through this pandemic
one of the things that we're doing is
recruiting more staff and we've already
recruited an extra 12 000 nurses
just before i let you go animal
protection what's the plan
animal protection yeah um i know that's
why you were here
oh no no oceans it's today is world's uh
oceans today
ocean's day and we are um announcing
today that we're going to
accept the recommendations of a review
that we will
put in place highly protected marine
areas this is where you would prevent
any activity there whether it's
extraction such as fishing or aggregates
or indeed even wind wind farms in order
to enable these areas to
fully recover and there are a lot of
benefits for the environment in doing
that so we're going to
pilot some of those sites okay well do
ocean day how are you going to celebrate
it
uh well i should be doing it's very
close to our heart here at sky we love
the oceans as you know we have
massive campaigns today we do and i
think the public are very concerned
about
plastics in our nations i'm very
concerned about some of those uh
threats to marine life and indeed
overfishing and it's one of the big
issues actually that'll be on g7
indeed you you're going down there this
week i should be going down on wednesday
night uh
it's happening just across sometimes bay
my constituencies at the other side of
that
i've got a number of events that i'll be
attending fantastic it's good to talk to
you thank you so much for taking the
time to join us this morning